hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren aktuell findet hier in Köln die
größte Videospielmesse der Welt statt
und zwar die gamescom und die gamescom
lockt nicht nur zahlreiche Besucher mit
den ganzen spielen an die J ausgestellt
werden sondern auch eine Menge Gaming
Youtuber und das bin auch ich
ich bin da dieses Jahr allerdings nicht
und als ich eben genau das gestern in
einem Twitch Livestream gesagt habe sind
sehr viele von euch regelrecht
ausgerastet weil sie dachten sie können
mich dort treffen und ich war auch die
letzten Jahre da und vor allen Dingen
Monaten hatte ich das ja auch so halb
mehr oder weniger durch die Blume gesagt
angekündigt dass ich gleich da sein
werde ich bin dieses Jahr allerdings
nicht da
und das hat jetzt nicht irgendwie den
Grund dass ich die gamescom hasse dass
ich irgendwie Stress mit der
Organisation da habe oder irgendein
anderer crazy special Grund sondern es
ist mir einfach zu viel das merkt ihr
auch schon als ich beispielsweise vorne
Monat ein Youtube Video hochgeladen habe
nämlich gesagt habe dass ich vor als
Pause mache ist ja erstmal ein bisschen
weniger Content auf dem Hauptkanal kommt
und jetzt auch aktuell alle drei bis
vier Tage nur ein Video kommt wo ich vor
ein paar Monaten noch bei nahezu daily
Uploads war ich habe einfach in den
letzten Monaten gemerkt dass das ganze
Drumherum um meinen Job über den ich
wirklich extrem happy bin und sehr froh
dass ich das als mein Beruf ausüben darf
also ich möchte mich überhaupt nicht
beschweren um Gottes will ich möchte so
versuchen zu erklären ich habe einfach
in den letzten Monaten gemerkt dass ich
so ein bisschen an meine
Belastungsgrenze gestoßen bin mit
täglich Sport machen Training von
Marathon daily Youtube Videos auf dem
Kanal daily Youtube Videos auf dem
zweiten Kanal mit Highlights Twitch
Livestreams der Podcast und alles was
drumherum gehört und die ganzen anderen
Themen
beispielsweise
immobilienvermietungen dann steuerkrams
alles mögliche ist ein bisschen in
meinem Kopf gewachsen weshalb ich mich
ein bisschen mehr zurückgezogen habe ein
bisschen weniger aktuell hochladen und
das auch der Grund ist warum ich jetzt
alle Termine rund um die gamescom
abgesagt hatte es waren eigentlich coole
Sachen geplant mit Zuschauer Treffen mit
Gewinnspielen live Giveaways vor Ort mit
Marken Kooperation generell ich hatte
eine coole Idee mit Sandra wir wollten
verkleidet über die gamescom laufen als
SpongeBob und Patrick verkleidet und
dazu auch ein Video drehen aber ich
brauche einfach mal so dieses
chillen
und das ist der Grund ich hoffe ihr seid
mir nicht böse ich hoffe ihr habt
trotzdem eine super coole gamescom Zeit
weil es werden wieder geile Games
vorgestellt und Köln lebt unnormal
gerade jedoch dachte ich mir als
Ausgleich machen wir die gamescom
einfach mal in virtuell im wir spielen
youtubers live 2 ich würde sagen wir
ziehen in die Innenstadt und das ist das
Hightech Viertel bekannt für seine Game
Stores Computerläden und Fitnessstudio
ja guck mal perfekt
äh der sieht ehrlich gesagt schon 12 aus
wie ich das ist 1 1 ich habe sogar
weißes T-Shirt an und sogar so eine Hose
ich habe
wir sind angekommen
in unserem neuen Viertel sieht alles so
aus wie gamescom ehrlich gesagt also das
neue Messegelände hier in Köln die haben
das extra alles umgebaut und das ist
Xavier safe Xavier Naidoo
besser nicht das jetzt also unser neues
Zimmer hier und wir haben auch schon
direkt hier ein Paket bekommen das
können wir jetzt einfach mal öffnen und
darin befindet sich ein Helm
nee das ist Roboter eine Drohne hallo
ich bin eine Kamera Drohne dein
persönlicher aufnahmeassistent piep piep
bitte gib mir einen Namen
es kommt eigentlich nur einen Namen in
Frage Sandra
ich liebe es okay es freut mich Dich
kennenzulernen ich werde hier sein um
dich aufzunehmen und zu helfen man immer
Du mich brauchst erster Schritt wähle
deinen Youtuber Namen und der stelle
deinen Kanal auf Youtube youtube ist die
Plattform auf der die besten
content-ersteller ihre Videos
veröffentlichen willkommen Youtube
aufrufen die durften es wahrscheinlich
Youtube denn aufgrund der rechte
Thematik mein Name wähle einen Namen wir
machen mal zufällig mit sia
was nee die lermo
Darion
Alexander ich dachte jetzt kommt so
Sachen wie super Player HD oder so
Freunde spaß beiseite wir machen es
natürlich genauso wie hier in echt auch
auf meinem YouTube-Kanal von einer ich
mich Luca mein Kanal heißt Laser Luca
und ich habe am 21 Geburtstag wir
bestätigen einfach mal die Änderung
Sandra sagt schöner Name Luke danke
nun kannst du dein erstes Video
aufnehmen willst du ausprobieren wie ich
funktioniere überrasch mich ich würde
sagen wir machen das einfach mal so
das ist mein Aufnahmeort
ach solche Orte gibt es überall in der
Stadt das heißt wir können überall
Videos aufnehmen nimm deinen ersten
Block auf also wir können mit unserer
Kamera wohl rein zoomen und auch wieder
rauszoomen und können auch mit X die
Kamera wechseln und dann auch rein und
raussuchen ich weiß jetzt
es geht los du sagst schüchtern hallo du
kommst voller Energie rein
ach jetzt muss ich mich schnell
entscheiden nee ich komme voller Energie
rein gut der Hund deines Nachbarn fängt
an zu bellen aber du schmeichelst dir
selbst du hast ja ich habe ein
Lachkrampf natürlich habe ich einen
Lachkrampf ein poltergeistert auf und du
sagst WTF okay ich versuche gerade alles
so zu machen wie ich selber glaube ich
reagieren würde du verabschiedest dich
und das ist vorbei du bitte zum
Abonnenten und es ist vorbei ich
verabschiede mich natürlich bitte ja
nicht um Abonnenten quatschen sowas auf
Youtube gemacht Luca jetzt müssen wir
das Video auf YouTube veröffentlichen
zuerst auf deinem Computer bearbeiten
ich muss den Dreck selbst schneiden das
wäre wirklich wie ein echt hier also
wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe
haben wir zwischen den Clips ja hier
unten in der Timeline so verschiedene
Teile die müssen miteinander verbunden
werden das heißt wenn ich ihn jetzt
nehme und jemand verbinden und dann
verbindet er sich hier oben hier unten
hier da das Problem ist allerdings
ich kann das nicht perfekt auf 100 %
machen
eigentlich relativ clean ähm das gibt's
ja allerdings nicht deswegen nehmen
Titel namens oMG das ist mein Haus von
der veröffentlichen wir jetzt mal unser
neuestes Video hoffen dass alles klappt
und wir sammeln die ersten likes
hast du gesehen dass ich die
angesagtesten Videos um Videospiele
drehen aha um diese Art von Videos
aufzusehen musst du zu Hause eine Gaming
Ecke einrichten Komma nauwe talking du
kannst die Gaming Ecke über die
fähigkeitsbaum-app freischalten Sandra
wird sie auf deinem Handy installieren
okay Sandra Fähigkeit vom app ist
installiert perfekt super okay Klasse
gehen wir mal in die Fähigkeitsbaum App
und schauen mal ob wir uns eine Gaming
Ecke vielleicht gönnen können bist du
sicher dass das kaufen willst ja sehr
gerne installieren das ganze auch direkt
und
wir können es auch drehen
ja machen wir so oder hier ist doch
super klasse
von daher würde ich sagen schauen wir
uns jetzt erstmal hier in unserem
Viertel ein bisschen um hier sind ja
überall Leute können wir mit den reden
okay dann müssen die Tage auch noch ins
Rathaus gehen hier ist Barack Obama moin
Meister ich wusste nicht dass das Spiel
so komplex ist aber gut es kostet halt
auch 40 €, ne hier ist auf jeden Fall
Player 1 das ist nämlich der Laden wo
wir uns eine Konsole und ein Spiel
kaufen müssen denn nur mit einem Gaming
Ecken Setup können wir noch lange keine
Gaming Youtube Videos aufnehmen deswegen
sollen wir mit leer quatschen wurde uns
gerade gesagt hier ist Player highler
wie geht's kann ich dir irgendwie helfen
Xavier hat mich geschickt oh du bist der
neue Youtuber
oh mein Gott
schon wieder an alter hey Luca hast du
das Spiel die Konsole schon ja habe ich
ich bin direkt hin gelaufen super jetzt
lass uns ein erstes Gameplay aufnehmen
perfekt das heißt wir können jetzt
wieder nach Hause laufen und die Konsole
erstmal anschließen und das Spiel
installieren die beste Zeit guck mal das
stinkt
wundervoll und sie guckt sich das an
Klasse hier vorne geht's nämlich den
Restaurant guck mal da kann man
wahrscheinlich auch noch ein Video
drehen tatsächlich dann irgendwann
geht's wahrscheinlich runter da kann man
auch noch ein Youtube Video drehen also
es geht anscheinend einiges ab in dieser
Welt ich laufe jetzt allerdings erstmal
nach Hause und versuche meine Konsole zu
installieren wenn ich mein Zuhause denn
überhaupt finde
ist eine esportbar
darum habe ich den gewohnt 10 Stunden
später schließen wir jetzt erstmal
unsere Konsole an und packen unser Spiel
dahin perfekt zurück und jetzt können
wir hier ein Video aufnehmen
das tue ich allerdings nicht denn ich
bin hier in der Rohraufnahme schon bei
45 Minuten und wenn ihr einen weiteren
Teil youtubers live mit laserluca etwas
wirklich 120 wenn ihr einen zweiten Teil
haben wollt dann lasst einen Daumen hoch
unter dem Video hier da abonniert meinen
Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke weitere
Videos zu verpassen ich jetzt nicht auf
die gamescom sondern Schneide jetzt
dieses Video und gehe dann ganz schön
entspannt schlafen haut rein tschüss